All. Yes. Working on.
The upside to working
in the minutia is well.
I think each of us gets a
certain amount of kudos from.
Being involved in the menus. I can.
It's something we can talk about with
other people that isn't doesn't involve.
Somebody else's life or.
What somebody has got up to
or you know the usual gossip
that you know mainly get into think because
there's nothing else to talk about
that.
Yeah something interesting to talk about
is always something happen in these and.
Developing ideas and and
skills and all the rest of it.
And then emmanuel's as a whole
people really do support it in.
It's not really that hard to say
with the advertising and all
that we are the cheapest around. That's
still the cheapest yeah for sure.
Oh yeah well you know my. We.
Know people you know say
i feel really good.
You know it's depp est
one yet. They're great.
What about you
and room for you.
While they've treated it like it's an
auditing which i suppose is in a way. Some.
It is an odd place it's very
different. Oh anywhere else. It's.
It's got so many good points to it
and it's got its bad points too.
You know i mean people are people they're
going to be nasty sometimes and.
But there's so many good
things happening here that.
It's very interesting place to be i
suppose it's especially working from this
office. It's.
Infinitely interesting.
What.
I've been doing between
eight and nine years.
Shows. Nimbin. The world is now
the place like it is there.
I really believed. The ideals that were.
About it about it.
You know the peace loving brown
life and getting back to nature
and all those sorts of things.
That is simplistic why
i've seen them been.
As changed for me not the same anymore.
There's a certain amount
of disillusionment.
As far as the human nature
part of it is concerned but.
That's more to do is my
expectations than anything to do.
I mean human beings have been
human beings for how long.
I should have got the message by now and i
have you know i mean. But then i hadn't.
And i sort of thought it was going to
be how i thought it was going to be
but it was how it is. You know i mean.
Prisoners are going to come and it
was it was the way it was then.
Still happening. What they
were not. When im been.
Nimbin there's change with there all the
stresses and strains and experiences
that nimbleness had. It can
only really be how it's evolved
and it's evolved into what is now certainly
hard to see what it is now that.
Just walking around town
and seeing a surviving little township
you know lots of people lots of people
smiling. You realize that you
know we've all got these.
The dark side and the
downside of life but.
On the whole nimbin you
know quite a happy place.
In terms of who told you why on my return.
Why do you pick you know me you know.
I don't can't really
speak for anybody else.
I mean i know they don't
take much notice. But.
I think people always pick what
they don't understand and.
Whatever new angle you're
trying to put over
or a new thing you're trying to live is
going to be attacked from all sides because
it's a threat to the given water.
Whatever's existing for everybody else
out there is is all they know and.
If you tryna live something a little bit
different. It's not that much different.
Then it's going to be attacked.
It's going to be brought down
it's going to be misrepresented.
It's going to be laughed at going to
be school and. It's all those things.
It is other people's reactions to name
then it's not really anything to do with
women. Like that and see
how you love children.
What's different before.
It was different because i
just moved out of a marriage.
So it was going to be different.
Anyway. It was very different.
I had to try and overcome living alone.
I mean alone really alone. Alone and.
Not having next door neighbours
so much and stuff like that. And.
I decided i can't.
Yeah i think libyans are very very social
beings i like a little be a balance
and balance isn't one.
I don't think maybe that's something
i still got to learn but it hasn't.
I haven't accomplished it yet.
So.
Yeah yeah. The isolation.
All the difficulties were really i mean
at that stage i think i wasn't so tired
that stage all the difficulties were.
Pounced on with glee if you like you
know the tics and leeches ha ha ha.
You know i hear his take.
I have you know you sort of
think it's a big game and.
And this just shows how.
How you roughing it and you know
they're all that sort of stuff.
Now ticks a nuisance.
And you know. The hype.
Yeah well it was i mean i
can't speak for anybody else.
I mean maybe other people had a different
expectations and ideas that are.
There. When i have to
stop this and how i can.
I. Right.
Where i'll be great. T.a.
Just won t. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm glad to see you
and i came to the area a month after
the aquarius festival came to nimbin
and lived around nimbin in many
places for three years and.
And then became body farm came
part of body farm when it started.
In we moved to 1977.
And the reason
that we got this place was because of
the meditation centre up the road which
many of us had helped to build and found
and we wanted very much to be close to
that at that time we felt that.
Meditation practice was a really
important part of all of our lives
and yet we wanted to raise
families and so on.
So we thought we'd have a
sort of like community.
Yeah yeah. Yes.
Well many others had lived in
india travelled in the east.
Some of the people who formed this community
had virtually come directly from india
and in fact came to the area because of
christopher titmus who gave the first
retreated the meditation centre and
that was really their main
interest in our lives at
that time my very most
important thing. So.
We'd all had a lot of experience in
buddhist practice and just wanted to share
that in mutual support in that practice
was what we felt we could have here.
Just got. Describing body farm.
It's a hundred and fifty acres.
Much of which is at a 45 degree
or greater angle with lots of forest
and we came here the trees the
regrowth was about 25 years old.
The trees continue to
grow taller and taller.
We have very little cleared land really
just enough for tubes and gardens.
And we've got about 13
dwellings going along to two
little roads.
Most couples are single people
have their own shelters.
There's some arrangements where
various facilities is shared.
I i have a sort of exploding house
that i share with my present
husband my son his two sons
and another woman and her daughter.
So there's lots of different
living arrangements
and then we have this wonderful large
community centre which we built together some
years ago where we get together for
dinner cage nally and have parties
and meetings play together here.
I can't quite see nimbin
it's hidden by the hills
but it's really very close
as the club crow flies.
There's a lovely tangible creek down
the bottom of our property and.
We've got another community on
one side as our neighbours and.
So sort of commercial
operation on the other.
To. Yes.
There wasn't a single shelter
here there's a bit of us.
Law from some house where
they've been changed to bits
and taken away.
I lived with my partner at
that time you know 15 foot caravan
americans who lived in a tent down the
road.
There were two other guys i guess
they must have been intense
that was about it at the beginning
there was about four of us
and we just rated where how to build
a shelter where we could cook
and stuff so we did
that in a very piecemeal way none none
of us had virtually any experience in
building and being very sort
of idealistic about making it.
Our own way we had no power tools
we did all our buildings by hand.
Everything by hand lot of work and a lot
of learning which is quite fantastic
that we took that on we
had no water. No nothing.
And. It's interesting that in the first
year just heaps of people flocked here.
I think by the time we were two years old.
We had 30 people staying here under
the most difficult conditions
and a tiny tiny community space
in which we a together every day.
And we had eight babies in the first year.
Eight babies in tents mine
was born in the caravan
and so we were busy having babies
and building our very basic
houses at the same time.
It was quite it was quite
stressful and quite challenging
and we had a tremendous sense
of helping each other.
People were drawn because they i mean
immediately had a reputation as a spiritual
community which can work both. Ways.
People can say very nice things about
you know very scathing things about you
and we've had plenty of both.
And i'm sure we've deserved.
You know if you if you set yourself up
to have a lot of ideals your really good
target. But yes a lot of those
people were really interested in.
In meditation practice or buddhism
or you know something like
that was what drew them here.
I think that we were very lucky and that
the people who began this community.
It was like a good chemical mixture.
It worked and there was really
very little conflict and
that attracted people as well as.
Well.
I'd say we experimented with
or inquired into the basic buddhist
precepts which involve killing
stealing issue of what's called false
speech false speech which is truly trying
to be as truthful as possible.
Not taking intoxicants which
was never totally strict
but was quite strict early
on things like that
and we also expected everyone
to do a retreat every year and
that if someone wanted
to join the community
that they really needed to know what
that was about to do a
retreat was important.
We know early on did we by
many other teachers around
but in the later years we've had some
wonderful spiritual teachers come here
like teach not hahn whose vietnam era.
The man who we built the meditation centre
forward teach in comes back he was here
again. It's here. Christopher.
So we have a very much an
ongoing relationship with him.
We've organized we treat them like
bakker who's sort of in the lineage of
krishnamurti
and numerous other be
passionate teachers so
that was very very obvious
at the beginning.
It's not like when you're
not unique in that
and under cross the ridge also has
a very strong orientation towards
but a spiritual practice to. Did.
Exist.
Yeah it was quite strict i mean when you.
So many of us first met these ideas
in india or nepal some place like
that in the idea what does it mean
not to hire any living thing.
Well virtually that's impossible.
But yes i mean in the beginning we
didn't kill mosquitoes which bitters and
when blowflies bitters nuttall of those
much flies bit us. We didn't kill them.
We simply tried to rattle their brains.
You know hands so they
didn't travel us too much
and i mean it's easy to be
cynical or scoff at that now
but it's really quite
interesting to play with ideas
and see how far you can go with that and.
And that's true with that
looking at all those precepts
and i think what we came
to within a few years was
that there's no actual action or non
action that has to be adhered to.
But that your conscious all the time
of what you're doing and more and more
that i think become our shared
inquiry is to really be willing to
just say ok well is this.
Really something i want to do and and
when i kill this creature am i
aware of it is it necessary.
Is it you know just really
thinking about what we do
and our lives.
Yeah yeah that's a bill
miller thacker uses
that word into instead of meditation
and i think everybody here would agree
that that's what we're that's what you know
insists is a dedication to inquiry for
ourselves and to share
that and to acknowledge
that it's a bit different for everybody
but it's really good to share it and
and how they other people reflect back to
you how they feel about your inquiry to.
Yeah i know one of our main
claims to fame and i must say
that being attacked by the
government even on the local level.
It's like an outside threat is a wonderful
thing to unite a community and.
My memory may not be as clear as
some other people here on that but
when the fight for the train you
creek rain for asd came to a head.
Chris bodey farmers many other places around
were deserted everyone was down there
and the local community.
In some ways took that struggle
as a real affront to something
that they thought was theirs and.
It was only at that stage that the
local council said hey wait a minute.
You never asked for permission
to build on this land.
We've never even heard of you.
I mean they had to have known we were
doing what we're doing but that was.
They just had had enough
with their troublemaking
and suddenly said you can't do. That.
And the whole movement for multiple
occupancy sort of sprang from
that conflict.
And a lot of people who were
very active in that movement
and in the what it ended up ended
up happening with bertie farm was
that we had demolition demolition orders put
on two of our houses primarily because.
They didn't have four walls
they had three walls.
Before
that there was a lot of question of whether
we had the right to their building
standards weren't good
enough and sydney uni
and all kinds of people got involved
with testing the strength of our timbers
and years found out
that ron brown polls are ever so much
stronger than a similar sickness of square
poles and so on but in the end
we had a demolition order
and two houses for five years
which eventually went the land
and environment court and. We are
all really enjoyed the hearing.
Whatever you call it that happened.
One of those houses was mine and and.
I look back now and i i would feel the
same way if it was done over again.
I can remember saying to my partner. Well.
Let's build the bleachers for the audience
to watch this place being bulldozed you
know how fantastic because
in fact when we all
when all of us first built here are a very
important idea to us was to do minimally
and to create something where we wouldn't
be too tied up into material possessions
that our house wasn't didn't
take a huge investment of time
and money in therefore you
have to worry about it
and that's in the spirit
which we approached
that conflict was not being
terribly worried if we lost
that it would be quite a good bit
of theatre and quite a statement.
But in fact it did you
nineties and we learnt a lot
and we became very involved
in the community because of
that. Yeah yeah.
When is a room not a room. Yeah and i
mean they're the questions that the.
The council q.c.. Put was you know.
Well i mean this is terrible.
What about the welfare of children
vermin snakes coming in our queues see
question well what's sleep out for and and
there's more if it's got a television
and a bed in it.
And so it was very interesting some time.
You mean men and women's
relationships. I don't know if.
I don't think the actual physical stresses
that we underwent such as not having.
A stove or a hot water
or about through a place to wash nappies
really was a strain on our relationships.
It was.
I think a big internal strain for individuals
because it was like i mean we didn't.
None of us grew up in communities.
People don't in the western world
and you have to learn all kinds of things
which you don't have to know about
when you live in a nuclear situation.
So in that way it is very
stressful in the fact that.
Things that every family have to do
such as nappies is quite a huge job
when you don't have much
to do it with. And yet.
We had to build our houses and
cook for 30 people every day and.
I know. Tell us. Fine.
We had to drive the chain and
to make a phone call and all
that sort of seeing as that's sort of
what i meant by stressful a lot of
i'm wondering if i can say if there's any
single relationship which remained intact
over the period of this
community which is now 15 years
and i think no but that is not unlike.
People are age in the wider community.
Some of us who've established relationships
with people who are on the community.
You know like you could say people have
changed partners really not quite like
that but.
Yes people who've lived here
and dissolve relationships have
made new ones with other people on.
This. Cause.
But that's been a common.
Well i don't know a lot
about other communities.
I i think they have a feeling
that we communicate really well.
Of course there are tensions between us
people you know we see things differently
want things to be done differently.
But we've always managed to get through
it without a real crisis. And yes it is.
We don't live all that close
together. Really moment to moment.
So that's not.
A really big problem but just like you
know i shared a house in the city
or anything like most of the most of
the time i in fact have shared me.
I might shelter with other couples or.
People and two people and a
child and one prisoner child.
And yes that stressful but i
think lots of people experience.
The stressors who don't live in communities
to students you know it's very much the
same.
For the structures.
Well the place was incredibly chief.
It wasn't a real hot property.
It was coal it's cold ravished by
the locals because it's old trees
and state so it was only
sixteen thousand dollars
and we decided at the beginning
that they'd be $1000 shares.
So i didn't take long for
us to pay for that. And.
It was only after a number
of years when we realized
that for new people joining
that maybe the share price should go up
at the moment i think it's still under
$4000 for a share.
It's just very hard for
someone to get us to agree
that they can be a shareholder
the structures that we set up.
We set ourselves up in the cheap legally
in the cheapest way possible which was a
company which.
Was sort of under a voluntary association
because that's a very very cheap way of
forming an organization much cheaper
and simpler than a cooperative so we were
a voluntary association because those
selves the body church churches
are voluntary associations
and formed a company. And we have
trustees the land is held in trust.
But what what a voluntary
association means
that the place cannot be sold it
has to be passed on to another.
There's such organisation and that was
one of our big ideals was that. Ok.
We're going to get a hold of this in
this piece of land can never be bought
and sold again we decided
that shares were non-refundable and
that everything here
belonged to the communities.
So technically speaking our houses do not
belong to us they belong to the community.
Day to day organisation involved
and i think we've got it down pretty
well liked in the beginning we only had
community cars. So we had a car
system a car booking system.
Cars had parents who looked
you know looked after them.
One person did the food
ordering another person and
when we did get a telephone to the telephone
bill someone else took care of the car
books and that's all still
in place today. And that.
Wasn't always easy
but i think a lot of people would say we've
got really good figuring those things
out so
that they were we pay into a
general kitty every week.
We save money. We decide on major
expenditures together we are operating.
I suppose you'd say consensus
minus one. We don't vote.
Sometimes we spend an awful lot of time
talking about things like we might talk
when we were going to build a dam we talked
about it for about three years every
reading and then we switched to some
other thorny subject which you know
and sometimes i think i meetings are so
long is just because we really do like to
talk and we.
We're to sort of active to do it socially
so we only have meetings as excuses to
talk for a long time for.
You know we've just develop strategies for
dealing with the stress of it like i can
remember early on i get headaches i'd
be shaking i'd feel exhausted in the
irritable after meetings and.
A lot of us with the you know where is it
not being so in it's a one community is a
wonderful way of learning not to be so
invested in your own opinions because if you
have a big investment over there
is just hell. I think that all.
How much trouble you can give yourself.
Yeah i do yeah i do think everyone
has has had to deal with that
and has gotten a lot out of it.
I think.
You know i think you know i.
When i hear about them as being
started now it's so often. Really.
Can i clear based which i mean it's fine
it's it's i'm more obviously because i'm
here for finding a way to live
that. Doesn't tied to sort of.
The tyranny of working you
know you know life away.
And. But i think same time i.
I wonder how it is you know how hard
a time communities can have like
that there are. Just throw up.